also wenn ich den jetzt so hoch wäre ich
lieber sagen der weg bestimmt drei kilo
dieses ding hier also dort kann ich habe
ist afrika werfen ihr könnt das hier
sehen das ist echt eine menge dreck aber
ich kann euch versichern
mein gerät würde es ohne probleme alles
wegputzen
deswegen gibt ihm höhe 18 euro roboter
ich bin mal gespannt was geht ab und
herzlich willkommen bei einem neuen
video gerade hatte ich hoffe natürlich
geht es gut
heute gibt es ein video das wirklich
sehr sehr spontan entsteht also ich muss
euch sagen ich bin gerade voll im hasse
ich habe gestern und vorgestern drei
videos produziert an einem tag also in
zusammen sechs stimmen des vorproduziert
auf jeden fall alles coole videos kommen
jetzt jeden tag um 19 uhr oder
vielleicht manchmal auch erst um 20 uhr
kommt darauf an wie es schaffe heute war
eigentlich wieder einen video angesetzt
das problem ist gewesen das produkt was
ich heute vorstellen wollte was wirklich
ein extrem geist produktes das kommt
auch noch ist irgendwie noch nicht da
ich hab's per express versand bestellt
aber es nicht da es kommt irgendwie
hoffe ich montag dann kamen ja ein
geistesblitz und zwar habe ich glaube
ich um weihnachten rum diesen
saugroboter bestellt der legt schiff
ewig dort bei mir im schrank ich habe
halt nicht ausgepackt weil irgendwie hab
ich kein bock drauf oder wurde haben
jetzt auch gar nicht mehr dran gedacht
ich muss nämlich sagen jetzt saugroboter
kenne ich mich mittlerweile echt gut aus
ich habe meine eigene
es ist 6 abs 5 ist wirklich ein top
gerät fährt er jeden tag um 14 uhr
einmal durch die ganze wohnung schön
saugen mit lasergesteuerte verbunden du
kannst sperrbereich einfügen also da
gibt es viele funktionen ist ein
chinesisches unternehmen glaube ich die
machen auch wieso elektro scootern
vielleicht der ein oder andere von euch
ich sag euch die kommen auf jeden fall
noch mal gut raus und wenn jemand von
euch so ein roboter so das ist auf jeden
fall ein modell was ursprünglich mal ein
placement auf diesem kanal war aber ich
kann mittlerweile sagen dass es ein
extrem geiles ding und hier habe ich
jetzt halt einen bericht bestellt der
hat damals 18 euro kostet ich kann euch
denn hier gerne einbinden
also 18 euro saugroboter da muss ich
schon seit grinsen das kann ja
eigentlich nichts werden und der
vermisste auch nicht die wohnung mit
laserpointern und fährt dann immer genau
seine linie
nein dieses ding fährt durch
wahrscheinlich nach dem chaos prinzip
das heißt es wird ein bereit stumpf
durch die wohnung geradeaus wand reden
sagt da lang trotzdem bin ich mal sehr
gespannt was er kann deswegen packen wir
denn jetzt mal aus hier alles auf
chinesisch oder japanisch was weiß ich
und lasst euch das auf der zunge
zergehen 18 euro für einen liter also
wenn nämlich auch nur ein kleines
bisschen überzeugt ist es schon in
ordnung ich brauche nichts von vornehmen
weil ich verstehe da eh nichts ja ja
wahrscheinlich einmal das ladekabel und
also der weg wirklich nix mein eigener
sohn porter hat er wirkt locker aber
nicht wenn nicht sogar das zehnfache
holte man kurz dann werdet ihr das
erkennen so hier haben wir das gerät ja
da sieht man ja schon ein kleiner
unterschied
ich müsste den markt wird sauber machen
also wenn ich den jetzt so hoch ich
würde sagen er wird bestimmt drei kilo
dieses ding hier also das cancha
westafrika werfen vielleicht 300 gramm
keine ahnung und vom durchmesser kann
man auch sagen deshalb deutlich größer
ihr seid ja auch nicht blöd kann man ja
ganz klar sehen bevor ich euch jetzt
gleich einmal den hier kurz zeige damit
auch die leute die eigentlich noch gar
keine ahnung von robotern haben
verstehen wie das funktioniert und wie
gut das funktionieren kann schauen wir
uns mal kurz die beschreibung von diesem
kleinen ring an weil ich will wirklich
mal sehen mit was da dran geblieben ist
vieles davon kann jetzt auch nicht
verstehen aber sowas wie cleaning random
also chaos prinzip der schaft 70 bis 90
quadratmeter anscheinend am stück
kapazität um die 1,5 liter genau also
was hat wenn man denn hierauf macht
gegen die muss ja der dreck landen
der lange hier in dieser kleinen kammer
kann sein dass ich da jetzt irgendwas
falsch verstehe aber das sind für mich
garantiert nicht 1,5 liter na gut hier
kann man den auflagen was diese beiden
kann man hier sollen weiß ich nicht also
das hat mein saugroboter nicht aber gut
vielleicht finden wir das noch machen
erstmal zu beanstanden auch akku obwohl
das schon ein halbes jahr in einem
schrank liegt das ist ja schon mal was
positives ich dachte ich muss ja erst
ein paar stunden aufladen noch ganz kurz
also wenn ich den hier aufmache fühlt
sich natürlich schon viel hochwertige an
hier haben wir die kammer jetzt fängt
sich halt der ganze staub und mehr
brauche ich dazu eigentlich auch gar
nicht sagen
dann würde ich sagen das wird schon mal
kurz auf meine kleine glocke mir und ich
zeige euch wie dies funktioniert habe
ich glaube ich auch schon mal irgendein
video aber wir machen das ganz schnell
und dann kommen wir auch zu diesem
sommertag ich bin wirklich gespannt
ich muss natürlich auch noch ein
bisschen dreck machen also ich habe den
dahin in der ecke installiert hier
schläft der praktisch immer lädt sich
von alleine auf das ist die ladestation
findet immer hier in den weg zurück und
ist halt darauf programmiert dass er
jeden tag um 14 uhr einmal durch die
ganze wohnung fährt und ich muss sagen
macht er wirklich gut ich zeige euch das
super gern nicht einmal in der app der
ist über die app gesteuert hier kann man
ihn sehen das ist unser ganzes
wohnzimmer habe jetzt schon 17 06 30
eben um 14 uhr hat er diese route
gefahren also einmal komplett alles
außer das badezimmer habe ich mal 0
eingestellt und wir drücken jetzt zum
beispiel auf gerät reinigt und dann
fährt er so ich bin jetzt mal gerade
hier in meinem zimmer gegangen
hier haben wir immer noch die app kann
man jetzt den wurde grad lang fährt da
würde das theoretisch wieder die ganze
wohnung einmal putzen aber das braucht
man eigentlich gar nicht weil die
wohnung ist aber bei uns ist hier gehe
nicht sauber es wird jeden tag gesagt es
wird aber eine woche gewünscht um mehr
jene kann man in einer haushalt nicht
haben und dann kann ich ja auf ihren
webseiten okay was auf 1000 paar wieder
zurück zum laden dann machte hier kann
man sehen der hat genau diese route
kennt alle gegenstände hat er mit dem
laser abgemessen und fährt halt genau
dann dran vorbei kommt eigentlich
wirklich fast in jeder ecke also das ist
ein kleines gerät dann geht wieder
zurück zum laden und das machte dann
auch der kann eigentlich auch deutsch
aber habe ich irgendwie noch nicht
eigentlich der suche
er rät wieder auch jetzt können wir uns
mal diesem gerät hier wird man nicht
vielleicht mega gespannt ob das ist raub
oder ob das überhaupt was aufsaugt weil
wenn man denn an macht
man hat ja so ein sog und der ist echt
nicht stark also bei dem ist 1000 mal
stärker ich würde sagen ich legte jetzt
mal so eine kleine dreck spur und dann
lasse ich den mal drüber fahren
ich hoffe das klappt auch irgendwie weil
der verteilt nach chaos prinzip einfach
irgendwo land dafür nehme ich jetzt hier
einfach mal diese apfel kammer raus
genau kann man ganz schön dreckig hier
drin vielleicht macht es sogar sind das
erste mal hier auf dem tisch zu testen
weil der ist halt so schön weiß da kann
man viel sehen das sollte eigentlich
auch schon reichen ihr könnt das hier
sehen das ist echt eine menge dreck aber
ich kann euch versichern
mein gerät würde das ohne probleme alles
wegputzen deswegen gibt die mühe 18 euro
ruhig roboter ich bin mal gespannt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ok also ich muss sagen besser als
erwartet deutlich besser ich habe ihn
jetzt hier so bestimmt drei vier mal
rüber fahren lassen also über jede
stelle natürlich wie gesagt aus prinzip
du musst immer auf achten dass sie
irgendwo gegen fährt um dann wieder zu
drehen wir haben natürlich hier noch
ziemlich viel dreck auch da das hat
irgendwie nicht aufgenommen aber an sich
kann ich wirklich sagen besser als
erwartet also für 18 euro ist es meiner
meinung nach in ordnung da kann man ja
auch nicht viel erwarten
ich brauchte was für mein zimmer damit
ich nicht mehr selber sagen muss würde
ich sogar sagen dass er vielleicht gar
nicht mal so schlecht ist ob wir so
billig varianten die sind in deutschland
gewässer sind mag zu bezweifeln ich
würde jetzt einfach noch hier einmal auf
den boden setzen und zu gucken ob er
sich schnell verfällt oder so und einmal
gucke ich noch irgendein wie das jetzt
hier drinnen aussieht kommt ja das land
alles optimale drin also nicht schlecht
ab und die auf dem boden ihr können
sehen hier steht ziemlich viel gießen
teppich dass ein teppich ich bin mal
gespannt was jetzt passiert
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das wäre jetzt natürlich schon mal
ziemlich schlecht wenn er nicht mal auf
diesem kleinen teppich kommt aber doch
kümmern
[Applaus]
ok warte man ja hmm
okay okay aber da fehlt auf jeden fall
ziemlich viel power
[Musik]
ja weil zu wählen der hin noch gewachsen
macht würde ich sagen das war's mit
diesem kleinen test sollte noch mal ganz
kurz als nachtrag natürlich er ist das
für mich persönlich jetzt nicht so
wichtig mir ging es nur um die saugkraft
aber viele von euch interessieren sich
bestimmt für die ladezeit und wie lange
der akku dann auch wirklich hält ich
habe mir jetzt mal komplett aufgeladen
das hat ungefähr zwei stunden gedauert
also dann habt ihr so ein lampe
beleuchtet und dann habe ich dann eben
mal umgedreht und hat einfach laufen
lassen und mal so ungefähr auf die zeit
geachtet und ihr sitzt ja hier aus an
dann geht nichts mehr also der ist
komplett leer und er ist ungefähr so 40
minuten gefahren also an sich in ordnung
genau also fährt 40 minuten getestet von
alex w ob man sich darauf verlassen
sollte bis eure entscheidung wie schon
eben erwähnt würde ich sagen immer halt
ein kleines zimmer hat wo nicht viel
teppich liegt nicht viel drin steht ist
so was vielleicht in ordnung nur bei den
dingen fehlt halt einiges auf jeden fall
saugkraft power aber wie schon gesagt
habe nur 18 euro kostet deswegen an sich
schneidet er meiner meinung nach viel
besser ab als ich erwartet hätte also
ich habe gedacht der kann eigentlich gar
nichts wo ich habe nichts gemacht
deswegen muss ich eigentlich sagen aha
das ist alles wieder raus gefallen das
ist natürlich auch nicht so gut
vorsichtig mit umgehen ich würde sagen
ich bin an sich überzeugt ja kann man
machen für 18 euro
das wars mit diesem kleinen test ich
hoffe es hat euch gefallen schreibt mir
weitere produkte schickte weitere
produkte die ich mal testen soll von
irgendwo in china seite oder von wo
immer gerne bei instagram da hat sich
alex w und wir sehen uns morgen um 19
uhr wieder da gibt's neues video morgen
das video wird verdammt cool ich hoffe
ihr seid dabei aber nicht vergessen